en Israël le Hamas a pris pour cible une
r partie à la frontière de la bande de
Gaza parmi les nombreux sites attaqués
par les terroristes palestiniens se
trouvait celui d'un festival de musique
électronique samedi au moins 260
personnes auraient été massacrées par le
Hamas lors de cette rêve partie certains
participants ont réussi à s'enfuir
d'autres ont été tués ou pris en otage
ces festivalier était réunis dans le
désert du Négev à proximité de la bande
de Gaza à ce moment-là il ne se doutait
pas que les terroristes du Hamas étaient
en train de lancer une offensive de
grande ampleur sur les IM et encore
moins que les points noirs dans le ciel
étaient des combattants palestiniens
jugés sur des ULM vers 6h 30 du matin
les premières roquettes tombent quelques
minutes plus tard des rafales se font
entendre selon des témoignages les
terroristes du Hamas ont tirés sur la
foule les voitures et utilisé des armes
lourdes contre les festivaliers les
services de secours eux ont annoncé
dimanche avoir retrouvé au moins 260
cadavres sur le site et des vidéos
montrent que beaucoup de personnes ont
été emmenés de force et pris en otage
plusieurs ressortissants étrangers
semblaient être présents dont un
Britannique de 26 ans portait disparu un
franco-israélien de 26 ans parmi les
victimes ou les personnes disparues ou
encore une allemande d'origine
israélienne Shani Luk qui est apparue
dans une vidéo choquante où les
terroristes du Hamas scche sur son corps
dénudé à l'arrière d'un
[Musique]
pickup